luke and tom here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're hiking
camping and exploring
every national park in utah and we're
doing it
in one trip
[Music]
our first national park on this trip is
zion's national park which is hands down
the most popular national park in utah
all right tom you ready to do this yeah
if you want to get into zion's national
park you pretty much have to park at the
entrance and take these shuttle buses
throughout the park but they're pretty
big pretty fast and pretty regular
our first stop in zions national park me
and tom we're gonna hike the narrows
there you go you little warmer
it's only 7 a.m and it's still pretty
cold out so
look at these canyon walls that's so
cool
that's the beginning of the narrows a
slot canyon with a river running down
the middle
that's where we go
that's not a bad one
the water's brisk
when the sun comes out and the heat of
the day is pounding down on you this is
one of the most refreshing hikes
but it's seven in the morning so it's
cold i can't feel my feet
there was a pretty serious flash flood
last night and the river volume was
about four times what it is right now
that's why the river's all chocolatey
brown
see town where it's ripley that's where
it's going to be fast and shallow where
it's calm it's going to be deep
now there's two ways to hike the narrows
you can either come from the bottom like
we did or you can come from the top but
if you come from the top and go
downstream you need to bring repelling
gear you need to get a permit and it's
really technical and challenging but
this has to be one of the coolest hikes
in utah
check it out guys there's a patch of
quicksand here
[Applause]
this is a pretty cool hike
in the summertime this hike can get
really crowded but after the first
quarter mile probably about 75 percent
of the people turn back the further you
go the more you have the place to
yourself
careful tom when you're wading through
the water you'll stub your toes on a lot
of rocks so you got to have good
closed-toed shoes with a lot of cushion
first time i did this hike i was wearing
reef shoes and by the end of the hike
both of my big toes were bloody
thomas it's job of the rock
that rock looks like jabba the
you hutt this is way cool yeah
i get so busy watching my step i forget
to look up
that's cool
suck it
in this little side canyon looks cool
you want to go for a swim
i'm not sure how deep that is but it's
definitely over tommy's head we'd have
to swim over there to get to it it's
still not that warm right now i'm not
sure we want to do that
you have a little slip and fall there
poor tom he just gets done saying he
doesn't want to get wet
and then he fell in
check out that big pile of rocks up
there you can see how deep it gets when
it floods the water level changes so
quickly the water was up to here about
1am last night
well me and tommy have been doing this
hike for about three hours but i think
it's time to turn around we've got so
much we want to see
has this been one of your favorite hikes
yes i want to come back
did you name your walking stick yes
nathan the walking stick
oh there's nathan save me nathan
save me
the water level's gone down about that
much since we got here
now that it's almost the middle of the
day and it's closer to the trailhead
you're getting a better feel for how
crowded this trail can get
it's time to set them free
[Music]
careful tommy they like to eat nuts
oh we just got out of the canyon and
that sun is intense
[Music]
listen would you like to go get some
food and go see a ghost town yes
apparently i forgot to pack knives so
i'm going to use a wheat thin
here you go tom
sike me gusta chittorons
we're only about five minutes outside
the front gate for zion's national park
and we're at the ghost town of grafton
it's one of the best preserved ghost
towns in the state of utah
what'd you find tom quickly
oh yeah you can eat those huh
oh
yeah
that's good actually
it's kind of like a pomegranate where
it's got all these little seeds with
flesh around them but it tastes a little
bit like a tart raspberry the spines on
the prickly pear are really fine they're
like little hairs they're really hard to
see and they get you
oh
they take a big barrel i fill it full of
water and then they pull it with a sled
so they can do their
check out laundry mud bricks this
staircase is moving a little bit
this is the church in the schoolhouse
which was built in 1886. i believe this
is where they film part of butch cassidy
and the sundance kid wants to get
but we are involved in it don't you know
that
again imagine going to school there
whoa
i don't think this was built for
somebody my hype
there's always
hey bud
it says joseph berry born 1843 killed by
indians 1866.
in the end that's what made grafton a
ghost town the navajo started raiding
here and everyone just left and went to
a nearby town for protection now some of
the local community members have got
together and are trying to preserve
grafton so this is all private this
isn't a park or a museum this is just a
community trying to preserve history
should we go check out another national
park
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're here at bryce canyon
national park and we use my annual park
membership hi
would you like a man oh yes please you
can pay either 20 to 35 to get into a
national park or you can pay 80 bucks to
get an annual pass for unlimited entries
you ready to see bryce canyon um yes let
me show you why we're here this
is bryce canyon isn't that cool do you
know what those pokey things are called
what hoodoos
dom what do you think should we go hike
down there yeah
whoa
yeah that's cool
don't drop the gopro
so me and tom are doing the navajo loop
trail it's about 1.3 miles and you go
down a whole bunch and then you come up
a whole bunch
you know what this part of bryce
canyon's called
the amphitheater
there we go guys that's the two bridges
got two stone bridges one up there and
one down there
how your feet feeling
well there's a whole network of trails
down here in the bottom of the canyon
and the navajo loop intersects a lot of
them so if we go that way we've got the
queen's loop which is about one and a
half miles
we go down that way and we've got the
peekaboo loop or we can go that way and
we can head back up the rim
hey
[Music]
well we did it tom was that hard work
yes
my legs feel like applesauce
if you don't want to do a lot of hiking
bryce canyon is one of the most drivable
national parks in utah you can see a lot
from the road does that sound a lot
better than hiking tom yes
[Music]
look at that that's pretty if you guys
want to do this without the crowds come
here on a sunny winter day it's
absolutely gorgeous
so
just one beautiful vista after another
you can just see him from do you know
why you're cold
because we're at 9000 feet above sea
level we're high up in the mountains
it was boiling hot down in zion's today
hey tell me was that worth the drive yes
tommy's done with hiking for today his
he's gummy
oh well let's go find something to eat
shall we
[Music]
that is an enormous plate of rice pilaf
is that your favorite
you're a rice pilaf beef top
there we go it's pretty yeah but it's
ice cream
well guys it's 9 30 and me and tom are
scrambling to go find a campsite of
course everything is jam-packed inside
the national parks so your best bet is
often to go to the smaller state parks
or the blm land that surrounds the
national park so we're gonna drive about
30 minutes to a little state park see if
we can't grab a campsite
i found a spot we're about 30 minutes
outside of bryce canyon at kodachrome
state park and there's probably 50 open
campsites and maybe two campers in the
whole campground much more privacy here
all right we got the tent set up it's
about 10 30. we need to get to bed we're
so tired
i slept pretty good last night except
for one little issue i woke up in the
middle of the night to my son unplugging
my mat
i was having a dream
i'm so sorry
what a great little campground
this is much prettier than the national
park campground and there's about 300
less people
so i have some granola some powdered
milk and some freeze-dried raspberries
i've got some ice from the cooler
you know i bought granola because it's
kind of traditional for camping i think
tommy made the better choice
all right guys next stop capitol reef
national park and to get there we have
to drive through the escalante grand
staircase which is one of the most
beautiful national monuments in the
country
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to stop here at the sun glow
motel and we're going to get some pickle
pie and some lunch
peanut butter chocolate truffle tequila
oh man
oh yeah we're going to do one of
everything
all right tommy you ready for this i'm
gonna start here with the pinto bean pie
it reminds me of azuki bean or uncle
bean if you've ever had that
like it
all right do the pickle pie
tastes a little bit like a pumpkin pie
with a tangy zip on it this tastes like
pumpkin pie so i'm okay with it oatmeal
pie it tastes like an oatmeal cookie in
pie form that's good
buttermilk
it's like a lemon meringue pie without
the lemon tom you're in utah you got to
try fry sauce
mixed together i think there might be
some mustard in there too
yeah they love their fry sauce here in
utah
oh i'm full are you
we just entered capitol reef national
park
capitol reef national park is the least
crowded of all the national parks here
in utah if you want to get away from the
crowds this is the park to go to but
even here the campgrounds are crazy
check it out this is the campground here
at capitol reef everyone's right on top
of each other and there isn't a single
space available it's full
all the national park campgrounds in
utah are like this just go to the
national forest or the blm or the state
parks instead you'll find much better
campground situations
all right we're going to take a drive on
scenic road and capitol reef national
park in my opinion this is the prettiest
drive in all the national parks in utah
check it out guys we're driving through
a wash
this road crosses a lot of dry riverbeds
called washes if we get a rainstorm it's
going to be flooded we have a hard time
getting back
let's get our water shoes on
all right guys me and tommy are doing
another hike we're gonna hike to the
sulphur creek pools it's a waterfall and
swimming hole it's only about one and a
half miles round trip but uh it's 90
degrees out so it is hot the water feel
good water feels nice
oh
watch out for cactuses we kick one with
these little dinky shoes and we're gonna
be in pain
check that out that looks like a lava
rock right there thousands of years ago
there was a lot of volcanic activity in
utah
there's lava tubes and extinct volcanoes
and hot springs
there's an old lime kiln tom put
limestone in there and you burn it up
really hot and it turns into quick lime
that you use to make mortar built by the
old mormon pioneers who settled this
area
[Applause]
oh that feels nice
[Applause]
i'll tell you the hikes we've done so
far on this trip were all awesome but
they were all really popular places this
nobody if you want to avoid the crowds
capital reef is where to go
look there it is
look at this tom
yeah i gotta do this
oh it's a little cold it's a little
bracing around the bits but other than
that it's refreshing oh my gosh
oh my gosh i'm in the difference
okay
whoa i'm swimming that's over my head
now oh no there's just okay i'm holding
on
ah all right i'm back on the ground
i can do this one hand
let's see
here you want to come with me did we go
and we drift back down
this feels nice doesn't it
i'm so tempted to climb up there and
jump off into the deep end but i tried
doing that in arkansas with tommy last
year and i cracked my tailbone so badly
took three months to heal
this is pretty fun isn't it
yes you know me and tom we saw hundreds
of people on our last two hikes but here
at capitol reef
nothing we haven't seen a single person
on this entire hike we have this entire
place to ourselves and we did just a
small portion of a four mile hike along
this river
so there's a lot more to see
tom i hate to save i think it's time to
go
we got a lot of ground to cover
oh
no it's cold isn't it
what do you think tommy was that worth
it
one nice thing about this dry desert
heat we're gonna be very dry by the time
we get back to the car
oh
thanks dad tommy's tivas are giving him
a blister so we're gonna give him a
little bit of assistance here i don't
want my hiking buddy wearing out before
the trip is over here we go this is the
national park visitor center and the
beginning of the sulphur creek trailhead
this is the visitor center parking lot
such smaller crowds here in capitol reef
there are loads of petroglyphs here in
utah and petroglyphs are prehistoric
paintings on the rock by the indigenous
people and up here you can see a bunch
of them you can see right there they've
carved into the rock pictures of people
and animals and other things there's
petroglyphs all along the edge of this
cliff face archaeologists believe those
were created between one to two thousand
years ago there's a boardwalk and a
bunch more petroglyphs down that way but
we need to make tracks
all right tommy next stop arches
national park
[Music]
what do i believe
what makes me feel it
to write you this song
all right guys that's arches national
park right there but we're not gonna
camp there we got to find a campsite
just a little down the road
look at this guys this is one awesome
campsite we're right here on the banks
of the colorado river and we're maybe
eight minutes from the entrance to
arches national park
that was easy
see that mark right there well we are
getting up early tomorrow morning to go
hike arches and so i'm getting
everything ready including taping up
tommy's feet a little bit so he doesn't
get any blisters had a little spot on
the back of his ankle that was feeling a
little bit raw so we put this blister
prevention tape on there that feel good
yeah it feels nice all right guys it's
late but we're getting up before the
crack of dawn we've got a busy day
tomorrow i'll see you guys then
[Music]
hit top you ready to go hiking yes it's
5 30 in the morning and you can see the
parking lot's already got about 20 cars
in it
all right guys we're in arches national
park and we are doing the delicate arch
hike
doing good there
one time up
we all went up the mountain
tell what do you think of this this
trail
welcome to delicate arch was that worth
the hike yes that was pretty awesome but
you can see it's a very popular hike i
mean
this is the crowd they got up at 5 00
a.m to go do this
me and tom are just sitting here
watching the sun rise on delicate arch
and it is a beautiful beautiful day and
best yet it's not 90 degrees yet
feels a lot nicer than it did in the
middle of yesterday didn't it
look at this
i think is that cool yes
now you guys can see this is a beautiful
hike and it's an icon of utah but there
are tons of wonderful hikes just like
this that aren't anywhere near as
crowded we got up at 5 00 a.m and you
can see there's probably 20 30 people
here already and it's just gonna get
hotter and busier as the day goes on
well me and tommy are gonna hustle down
this trail because we got a lot to see
here in arches you excited about that
tom
it's easy to get lost on the slick rock
part of this trail so there's these
little posts here every once in a while
you can see one there
and one there but if you come at night
it's really hard to see those and about
half the people on the trail get lost
and wander off it doesn't even feel like
falling but if you want to avoid the
crowds come in the off season if you
come in the winter it'll be a fraction
of the people here and you won't have to
do the hike in 100 degree heat
[Applause]
me and tommy ate too many dried apricots
last night and uh
he's running for it there's the bathroom
oh he's quick
all right you still alive for tommy
all right tommy go check out some of the
other arches yes
we're gonna do a quick walk up to
skyline art
and there's literally dozens of arches
like this in arches national park it's
right in the name you'll find that a lot
of these other arches are nowhere near
as crowded as delicate arch
we're gonna go take a stroll in the
devil's garden
this is the devil's garden trail and
it's about seven miles long and there's
lots of little spurs and arches along
the way
he's like hey guys
oh that sun's starting to come out with
force
check it out this is pine tree arch
this is cool
this is a fun hike and if you guys want
to do this too i'm going to put
information about all the hikes we did
in the video description for this video
this is the double arch trail in an area
called the windows there's probably
about a dozen arches right here in this
little valley
there's not a lot of good footing
oh just looked at the clock i better
hurry
we've got to catch a helicopter
hey tell me you want to go explore the
national park without having to do any
hiking yes
say goodbye to arches next stop
canyonlands national park
this is canyonlands regional airport and
we're going to see canyonlands national
park
by air
yeah that's cool smaller
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay i know the rotor is like way above
my head but it sounds like it's about to
chop your skull off i guess we're doing
the back okay
toby was that awesome yes it was
i'll tell you that was a pretty awesome
tour and it was a lot more affordable
than comparable tours in other areas if
you ever wanted to do a helicopter
flight scene tour this might be the
place to do it hey tom should we go
drive into canyonlands and see it from
the ground
yes
all right tom welcome to candylands
national park
canyonlands national park is broken up
into three sections there's island in
the sky in the north the needles in the
southeast and the maze in the southwest
it looks like they got some scenic
overlooks up ahead we're gonna stop and
check them out
one thing cool about canyonlands is they
have some amazing 4x4 trails down into
the canyon so we're gonna go down the
shaffer canyon trail
oh my goodness this trail drops right
off the side of the canyon wall
look at that
oh that drop-off is no joke tommy
hey tom is this scary yes i'm ready to
bail out
you like this tommy no yeah if you don't
like heights this isn't the trail for
you
i can get closer if you like no no no no
okay we'll stay back here
well i said capitol reef was the
prettiest drive of all the national
parks this is the most entertaining bad
news though we gotta go back up
that is an amazing drive
that was so cool
well i can't believe we just drove down
that
but this trail system goes on for miles
and miles just disappears off into the
horizon and there's dozens of trails
like this in canyonlands
unfortunately we're on a time crunch we
got to get headed back
all right tom you ready
yeah this is the aztec butte trail it's
about two miles long takes about 45
minutes to hike and it leads to some old
indian structures and archaeological
sites
got some rock piles here marking the
trail
just keep following those
there's another one
trail kind of dead ends here gotta
follow the rock piles now
[Music]
now these are the pantries this is where
they would store their food and medicine
and seeds and stuff so apparently the
native americans would live here
seasonally and when they were away they
would store all their valuables their
food their medicine their seeds in these
little rock pantries they could seal
them up and keep everything in sealed up
pottery the animals couldn't get it and
the weather couldn't get it and when
they came back it'd be ready for them
it's rocks and mud with sticks across
the top
yeah you got quite a bit of room in
there
this would be a nice little shelter if
you needed to get out of the sun
i think it was another one of their
pantries and look you see a big pile of
rocks right here too
doing good tom
oh i feel so nice yeah put that off oh
that feels better doesn't it tom
yeah
oh
it's a great wall and all but i wonder
what they use on their roofs
look down here there's another pantry
right here in the cliff face oh you can
see there's a whole bunch all along here
oh look at this
what do you think is this pretty cool
tom yeah
that's a house yeah look at that those
are definitely big enough to be houses
this is like the bedroom
oh yeah see this
that this one house
oh yeah
[Music]
that's a heck of a view right there
i understand why they lived here this is
nice and cool
i bet when you build fire in the winter
time it's nice and warm
this was so much cooler than i
anticipated i am so glad we came up here
if you guys want to do this too check
out the video description below for more
information on these hikes
save me
was this an amazing trip yes
i hope you enjoyed this video as much as
we enjoyed filming it if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel make sure to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning and check out our
travel adventure playlist and our
camping adventure playlist if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching